[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Es ist ja wieder Frühling, kurz vor Ostern.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber Karottenkuchen wird ja immer so
um die Osterzeit gebacken. Also so ein Frühjahrsrezept.
Ich liebe Karottenkuchen in allen Ausführungen.
Ich habe auch schon einige gemacht,
auch schon in meinen Backbüchern und auf meinem Kanal.
Jetzt kam mir so die Idee: ein Karotten-Cheesecake -
ein Karotten-Käsekuchen.
Okay, ich versuche mir echt, das Wort "Cheesecake" abzugewöhnen,
weil es ist ein Käsekuchen. Aber egal:
Karotten-Käsekuchen vom Blech.
Ihr könnt dann praktisch ein halbes Blech backen oder ein ganzes Blech.
Ich gebe euch natürlich die Menge auf meinem Blog und in der App an
und dann könnt ihr das Ganze hoch- oder runterrechnen
auf die Größe, die ihr eben zubereiten möchtet.
Ich mache zuerst einmal die Streusel, dann die Cheesecake-Füllung
und am Ende noch den Rührkuchen.
So ist es einfach von der Reihenfolge her perfekt.
Für die Streusel nehme ich 100g kalte Butter, 100g Zucker,
200g Mehl, eine Prise Salz und Vanilleextrakt
und für die Cheesecake-Füllung 250g Quark, 1 Ei, 30g Zucker,
30g Stärke und ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb.
[Musik]
Jetzt für die Streusel die trockenen Zutaten, also Mehl, Zucker, Salz,
dann die Butter dazu. Die darf, wie gesagt, gerne kalt sein.
Vanilleextrakt.
Also wer Streusel erfunden hat - das kriegt...
derjenige kriegt einen Ehrenplatz in meinem Herzen.
Ich finde, Streusel ist eigentlich, die beste Erfindung, oder?
Du hast es erfunden? Sarah hat sie erfunden.
Streusel sind so die beste Erfindung, seit es Kuchen gibt, finde ich.
Ja. Es ist einach ein Mürbeteig, aber einfach lecker.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Streusel mit den Händen oder mit der Küchenmaschine
einfach zerkleinern. Ich nehme da meist echt einen Teigzerhacker dazu.
Früher hieß der Mürbeteig auch Hackteig,
denn man hat es einfach mit dem Messer verbunden
und einfach mit einem Messer, mit so einem Wiegemesser
zack, zack, zack die Butter zerkleinert
und so wurde eben ein Streuselteig daraus.
So. Da jetzt einfach darauf achten, dass die Zutaten schön kalt bleiben.
Damit sie kalt bleiben, nimmt man da eben nicht die Finger dazu,
sondern wirklich ein Messer oder so ein Zerkleinerer oder eine Maschine.
Dann kommen die Streusel erst einmal kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Für die Käsekuchenfüllung einfach alle Zutaten
in einer Schüssel kurz verrühren.
Ich hab jetzt hier einen Magerquark, aber ihr könnt auch so einen
Sahnequark benutzen. Wird's noch cremiger.
Das Ei für die Bindung, die Stärke.
Wenn ihr jetzt so einen Kuchen vegan machen wollt,
dann könnt ihr auch beim Rührteig statt Ei einfach Leinsameneier nehmen,
d. h., 1 EL Leinsamen mit 3 EL Wasser
verquirlen und pürieren und stehenlassen.
Bei so einer Füllung einfach ein bisschen mehr Speisestärke.
Dann könnt ihr den Kuchen auch ganz einfach vegan zubereiten.
Bisschen Zitronenabrieb, aber nicht zu viel.
Soll keinen Zitronengeschmack haben,
sondern wirklich nur leicht zitronig schmecken.
Dann habe ich das hier auch jetzt fertig.
Den Ofen habe ich schon vorgeheizt auf 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze
und kann jetzt kurz eine Küchenmaschine holen,
euch die Zutaten für den Rührkuchen zeigen
und direkt damit starten. Ihr seht, das ist ein richtig schneller Kuchen.
Für den Rührkuchen nehme ich 4 Eier, 200g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz,
150g Sonnenblumenöl, 160g Mandeln (die werden noch gemahlen),
250g Mehl, 1 Päckchen Backpulver (das sind 3 TL), 1 EL Zimt
und hier habe ich noch 300g geschälte Karotten.
Also los geht's. Ich nehme jetzt hier den Zerkleinerer mit der Scheibe,
mit so einer feinen Scheibe.
Ihr könnt auch einfach einen Küchenhobel dafür nehmen, eine Küchenreibe.
Zuerst werde ich die Mandeln zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Da auch direkt die Karotten hinterher.
So, perfekt.
Wenn man im Prinzip am Anfang schon überlegt,
was in welcher Reihenfolge kommt, dann kann man sich echt
ersparen und etwas leichter machen.
Oh, das muss ich kurz wechseln.
[Musik]
Gut. Mit dem Schneebesen klappt das besser.
Jetzt nehmt ihr die Eier - die kommen da rein und werden dann
mit dem Zucker verrührt. Richtig schön cremig verrührt.
Geht auch mit einem Handrührgerät. Also ihr braucht keine Küchenmaschine,
aber die erleichtert mir natürlich die Arbeit.
[Musik]
Jetzt gebe ich einfach alle Zutaten hier rein und rühre sie kurz ein,
bis sie verbunden sind - aber wirklich nur kurz.
Sollte nicht überrühren. Sobald Mehl drin ist, nur kurz rühren,
sonst wird der Kuchen nämlich matschig und speckig und nicht locker.
Beim Sonnenblumenöl - das fragen mich oft viele,
welches ich da nehme. Also tatsächlich nehme ich gar kein
kaltgepresstes oder hochwertiges, weil bei denen das Problem ist,
dass die einen zu starken Eigengeschmack haben
und die darf man dann auch gar nicht erhitzen.
Deswegen habe ich da immer ein ganz neutrales Sonnenblumenöl,
eigentlich so ein recht günstiges. Ihr könnt auch ein Rapsöl benutzen.
Das schmeckt man dann auch nicht heraus, wobei meine Mama
mag Rapsöl z. B. gar nicht, denn wenn Rapsöl erhitzt wird,
empfinde ich auch so, riecht dann so ein bisschen fischig
wegen Omega-3, Omega-6 und dann...
Also ich rieche es auch, wenn es warm wird.
Deswegen nehm' ich am liebsten Sonnenblumenöl bei sowas oder Butter.
So. Viel Butter.
[Musik]
So sieht das super aus. Ich glaube, ich mache den Kuchen 30x30.
Oder ich mache erst einmal 25x25 und dann kann ich immer noch gucken,
denn ich habe den ja vorher nicht ausprobiert.
Der ist heute Nacht in meinem Kopf entstanden. [Lacht]
Dann war das so: "Probiere ich den vorher aus wegen der Größe?" Nein.
Ich mache ihn einfach.
Ihr könnt den übrigens,
auch wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt keinen eckigen Kuchen,
habe ich in meiner App und auch im Blog die Möglichkeit,
dass ihr runde Kuchen eckig umrechnet und eckige Kuchen rund umrechnet.
[Musik]
Aber ich muss doch zu meinem Ursprungsgedanken: 30x30 ist gut.
Dann wird er nämlich nicht so hoch.
[Musik]
Ich habe übrigens vor Kurzem - okay, vor Längerem habe ich, weil ich
Karottenkuchen so mag, und auch rohen Karottenkuchen,
habe ich einen Karottenkuchen-Porridge gemacht.
Schmeckt wie roher Karottenkuchenteig. Voll lecker
und ist ein richtig leckeres Frühstück und vor allem etwas Anderes.
Schmeckt richtig frisch und nicht so schwer durch die Karotten.
Also das war schon sehr, sehr lecker. Gell, Josh?
JOSH: Das war der Hammer!
SALLY: Das war der Oberknaller und sah genauso aus.
Gut. Der Josh hat es fast vergessen, aber ich nicht natürlich.
Ich habe noch eine Cheesecake-Füllung - Käsekuchenfüllung.
Die verteile ich jetzt so klecksartig darüber.
[Musik]
Dann gerne so ein bisschen verbinden, aber nicht arg.
Also wirklich eher so ein bisschen marmoriert lassen.
[Musik]
Dann verteile ich da jetzt noch die Streusel darüber.
Die drücke ich gern immer so ein bisschen zusammen,
dass ich größere Streusel habe,
weil die dann einfach schön knusprig werden.
Dann kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen,
wird gebacken, bis er gar ist. Danach lasse ich ihn abkühlen
und dann können wir schon probieren.
Also es ist echt ein sehr leckerer, schneller, einfacher Kuchen.
Okay, ob er lecker ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab ihn noch nicht probiert, aber es ist ein einfacher Kuchen.
3 Komponenten und alle auf einmal hergestellt. Hmm!
Magst du Karottenkuchen, Josh?
JOSH: Voll gerne, ja!
SALLY: Magst du dann verkosten?
JOSH: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Denn ich hoffe immer, wenn mir so etwas dann einfällt und ich so denke:
"Boah, das wird die nächste Kuchenkreation" -
dass es auch gut ankommt. Das weiß ich ja dann nicht.
JOSH: Ich bin gespannt.
SALLY: Ja, weil Theorie und Praxis sind oft schon anders.
[Musik]
Willst du einen Streusel?
SARAH: Ja.
SALLY: Oh Gott! Mach den Mund auf! [Lacht]
SARAH: Boah!
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Sie kommt zum Streuselnaschen.
[Backofengeräusche]
Ich liebe Streusel.
[Musik und Uhr]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken. Stäbchenprobe erfolgreich durchgeführt.
Jetzt kann ich ihn hier herauslösen.
Ich habe ihn auch schon abkühlen lassen.
Ich stell dann einfach immer direkt das Blech auf ein Abkühlgitter.
Dann kühlt es nämlich schneller und schwitzt von unten nicht.
[Messergeräusche]
So.
Dann die Folie darunter weg!
[Foliengeräusche]
Und wie durch Zauberei kommt der Kuchen frei.
Dann noch etwas süßen Schnee.
Wie Frau Holle.
Es sieht nicht aus wie ein Karottenkuchen, muss ich sagen.
SARAH: Könnten auch schon aufschneiden.
SALLY: Könnte... Ja, aber ich denke,
wenn ich ihn jetzt aufschneide, dann...
So, wie viele Stückchen machen wir denn?
Machen wir so oder machen wir kleine?
Mache ich so?
Oder kleine oder große? Sarah, wie hättest du es gern?
SARAH: Groß!
[Sally summt ein Lied]
[Schneidegeräusche]
So.
Der Kameramann mit dem besten Kuchengeschmack...
Warum schneide ich den Rahmen eigentlich weg? Naja...
Der Kameramann mit dem besten Kuchengeschmack steht schon
ehm...
JOSH UND SALLY: ... in den Startlöchern.
SALLY: Kurz vergessen, wie das heißt.
JOSH: Ja. [Lacht]
[Schneidegeräusche]
Soll ich starten?
SALLY: Ja, komm!
JOSH: Okay.
SALLY: Das war eigentlich meine Überleitung.
JOSH: Ah!
SALLY: Jetzt kommt dieses Huuuuuuuu.
JOSH: Huuuuu! Voll verka**t.
SALLY: Ja. [Lacht]
JOSH: Schlechtes Timing. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
SALLY: Das sieht doch schön aus.
JOSH: Ich glaube, ich habe so eine Kombi noch nie gegessen.
SALLY: Ich auch nicht. Ich hab nur davon geträumt.
JOSH: Hast du es überhaupt schon einmal gebacken?
SALLY: Nein.
JOSH: Wow! Okay.
SALLY: Aber ich mag Karottenkuchen, ich mag Käsekuchen
und ich mag Streusel.
JOSH: Dein Ernst?
[Sally und Josh lachen]
SALLY: Jetzt wisst ihr, wie ich das mache - schlank bleiben:
Ich esse immer nur so eine Scheibe.
Die anderen essen ein ganzes Stück.
Und wenn deine Umgebung dicker wird, siehst du umso schlanker aus.
JOSH: Ha... Al... Hallo? [Lacht]
SALLY: Aber er ist ja groß und stark und das verteilt sich.
JOSH: Ach klar! Deswegen auch das größere Stück.
[Sally lacht]
Aus der Hand? Ja, oder?
Mega lecker!
SALLY: Ich höre ein Aber.
JOSH: Aber, ich muss ausnahmsweise einmal sagen,
man schmeckt den Cheesecake nicht so wirklich heraus.
Vielleicht lag es auch daran,
dass ich keine Cheesecake-Füllung hatte bei meinem Biss.
SALLY: Ja.
JOSH: Vielleicht doppelte Menge von der Cheesecake-Masse?
[Sally stimmt zu]
Mehr so konstruktive Kritik.
SALLY: Warte.
JOSH: Bisschen?
SALLY: Es ist schon, ich glaube, ungleich verteilt.
[Josh stimmt zu]
Aber ich hatte auch außen ein Stück. Da war gar kein Cheesecake.
War aber auch nicht schlimm.
JOSH: Ja.
SALLY: Und dafür hatte ich jetzt ein großes Stück Cheesecake.
JOSH: Also ich fand das bei dem Red Velvet cool,
dass es so ein bisschen...
[Sally stimmt zu]
... weißt du, so richtig gleichmäßig verteilt war.
Crumble und Boden: Hammer!
[Sally stimmt zu]
Aber ich glaube so...
SALLY: Du bist eher so der...
Du hättest jetzt wahrscheinlich die Cheesecake-Füllung glatt drüber.
JOSH: Genau. Der Crumble ist ja dann trotzdem noch ein bisschen Deko.
Aber ein bisschen mehr Cheesecake-Füllung.
SALLY: Ich finde es trotzdem so schöner.
JOSH: Lecker auf jeden Fall!
SALLY: Weißt du, was ich hier schön finde?
Weil hier hast du einmal einen Cheesecake-Fleck
und dann so ein Kuchen, so einen gebackenen...
JOSH: Ja, ja, ja! Das ist schon schön!
SALLY: Aber wenn ihr wie Josh Cheesecake-Fan seid,
dann macht ihr die doppelte Portion an Cheesecake-Füllung, hmm?
JOSH: Auf jeden Fall.
SALLY: Einigen wir uns darauf?
JOSH: Ja, klingt gut.
SALLY: Das Rezept gibt es zum Nachlesen
[Sally und Josh lachen]
auf Sallys-Blog.de oder in meiner App. Ja.
JOSH: Okay. Passiert etwas Schlimmes, wenn ich es nachmache
und jetzt keine doppelte Menge nehme?
SALLY: Ja.
JOSH: Schon, oder?
SALLY: Dann geht dein Kuchen schief.
JOSH: Huch, okay.
SALLY: Ja, also schon doppelte Menge!
JOSH: Doppelte Menge!
SALLY: Okay. Also viel Spaß.
Ich finde, es ist ein schöner Blechkuchen, auch grad zu Ostern,
zur Frühjahrszeit - eigentlich zu jeder Zeit.
JOSH: Jetzt hatte ich so eine Stelle mit mehr.
[Sally stimmt zu]
Jetzt ist gut. So überall.
SALLY: Okay. Bleibst du bei der Meinung?
JOSH: Nein.
SALLY: Doppelte Menge?
JOSH: Also ja, doppelt. Ja. Doppelt.
SALLY: Okay.
SALLY UND JOSH: Tschüss.
[Musik]